Während die Augen der Weltöffentlichkeit
darauf gerichtet, wie Russland versucht,
eines seiner westlichen Nachbarländer
militärisch zu erobern, ist es Wladimir
Putin - weitgehend unbemerkt – gelungen, bereits
ein ganzes Nachbarland einzunehmen. Und das,
ohne einen einzigen Schuss abzufeuern!
Während nämlich alle über die Ukraine reden,
gibt es ein anderes Land, das mittlerweile weit
stärker unter die Fuchtel Russlands geraten ist,
als bislang von den meisten angenommen.
Es handelt sich dabei um eine Entwicklung,
die für Russland, die Ukraine und ganz Europa noch
weitreichende und gravierende Folgen haben könnte.
Von welchem Land hier die Rede ist?
Ganz genau! Weißrussland.
Für diejenigen, die dieses Land nicht kennen:
Wir sprechen von der letzten Diktatur in Europa.
Und wir sind nicht diejenigen, die
mit diesem Etikett um sich werfen:
Der Präsident von Belarus, Alexander Lukaschenko,
gibt es selbst zu, gar mit einem gewissen Stolz!
(Ein autoritärer Regierungsstil ist
charakteristisch für mich, und ich habe das
immer zugegeben. - Alexander Lukaschenko)
(Es ist besser, ein Diktator zu sein als
schwul - Alexander Lukaschenko,
Diktator von Belarus)
Mit anderen Worten: Weißrussland ist eine grausame
Diktatur. Und ihr Diktator scheint so fest im
Sattel zu sitzen, dass er es noch mal nötig
hat, den Charakter seines Regimes unter einem
Deckmäntelchen aus Lügen zu verheimlichen, so
wie es ja die meisten totalitären Herrscher tun.
Gut, aber warum behaupten wir dann eigentlich,
Putin hätte das Land erobert?
Nun, passt gut auf!
Am 27. Februar 2022 hat Weißrussland
eine wesentliche Änderung seiner
Verfassung beschlossen. Dies geschah durch ein
Referendum mit allen demokratischen Garantien,
die man von einem Land wie Weißrussland
erwarten würde: nämlich KEINEN.
Und diese Verfassungsänderung hat es echt
in sich: Sie erlaubt Russland, permanente
Militärstützpunkte auf dem Territorium von Belarus
zu errichten und dort auch Atomwaffen in großer
Zahl zu stationieren. Bisher entsandten die Russen
nur konventionelle Streitkräfte in weißrussisches
Territorium und das auch nur temporär, um
von dort aus z.B. die Ukraine anzugreifen.
Die die Errichtung russischer Militärbasen hinaus
will Moskau Minsk nun auch dabei helfen, eigene
mobile Raketensysteme ähnlicher der Iskander
zu bauen. Der Gegner ist natürlich die NATO.
In politischen und wirtschaftlichen
Angelegenheiten hat Weißrussland bereits
Abkommen mit Russland unterzeichnet, um eine
gemeinsame Politik in Bereichen wie Steuern,
Finanzen und Industriepolitik zu verfolgen. Das
ultimative Ziel ist die Bildung des sogenannten
"Vereinigten Staates", d.h., dass Weißrussland am
Ende eine politische Union mit Russland eingeht.
Wir haben darüber schon in früheren
Videos auf VisualPolitik gesprochen:
Der Kreml hat schon immer davon geträumt,
Weißrussland zu annektieren und zwar auch schon,
bevor Putin Präsident wurde. Der
weißrussische Diktator Lukaschenka
war jedoch immer sehr zurückhaltend in
Bezug auf eine vollständige Vereinigung.
Doch jetzt haben sich die Dinge dramatisch
geändert. Man könnte sagen, dass Lukaschenka
sein politisches Überleben Putin zu verdanken
hat und dieser nutzen den Krieg in der Ukraine
nun als Vorwand, um Druck aufzubauen und
die Annexion schneller voranzutreiben.
Ja, es stimmt, Moskau ist gerade dabei,
wirtschaftlich und militärisch auszubluten.
Der Angriff auf die Ukraine verlief für
Russland an fast allen Fronten verhängnisvoll.
Aber wir müssen fair sein: Was Weißrussland
angeht, könnte Putin einen echten Erfolg
verbuchen. Sozusagen ein Trostpflaster auf sein
imperialistisch-größenwahnsinniges Wehwehchen.
Die Frage ist jetzt: was würde passieren,
wenn Lukaschenka stürzt? Besser noch:
Was wäre, wenn es seine Unterstützung Putins
wäre, die Lukaschenka zu Fall bringt?
(Massenproteste gegen den
Krieg in Weißrussland: 800
Demonstranten festgenommen - Voice of Belarus)
Aber warte mal! Wir reden hier nicht nur über
Proteste. Die Bürger Weißrusslands tun alles, was
sie können, um den Krieg in der Ukraine zu stoppen
- viel, viel mehr als "nur" zu demonstrieren.
(Eisenbahnverbindungen zwischen Belarus
und der Ukraine sabotiert, um russische
Truppen zu behindern - Railtech)
Wir sprechen von Gruppen, die gut organisiert
sind und die den in Weißrussland stationierten
russischen Truppen das Leben
so schwer wie möglich machen.
Wohlgemerkt: es handelt sich nicht nur um ein
paar vereinzelte Widerständler. Im Moment kann
man sagen, dass Lukaschenka fast die gesamte
weißrussische Gesellschaft gegen sich hat.
Die Preisfrage lautet daher: Was ist mit seiner
Armee? Überlegt mal eine Sekunde: Ein Diktator
wie Lukaschenka muss seine Streitkräfte
unter Kontrolle haben. Was würde passieren,
wenn er diese Kontrolle verlieren würde?
Wäre es wirklich möglich, dass Weißrussland Putin
aus den Händen fällt... genau zu dem Zeitpunkt,
an dem es eine Region Russlands werden soll?
Heute werden wir all diese Fragen beantworten,
aber zuerst... müssen wir ein wenig Werbung
machen für unseren treuen Sponsor Surfshark,
der das heutige Video möglich gemacht hat.
Surfshark VPN ist ein wirklich sicheres VPN, das
ich auch selbst zu bisher vollster Zufriedenheit
nutzte. Ok, aber wozu braucht man eigentlich
ein Virtual Private Network – kurz VPN? Nun,
da wären gleich mehrere Vorteile. Zum
einen erschwert es im Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen, Eure Aktionen
im Netz nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören.
Es bietet unzählige Sicherheits-Features,
mit denen Ihr Eure Anonymität im Netz erhöht,
z.B. CLEANWEB, das alle Cookies-, Pop-ups
und auch fortgeschrittene Identifizierungs-
und Nachverfolgungsmechanismen sicher blockt
und die damit verbundenen Gefahren beseitigt.
Weiterer Vorteil eines VPN
ist, dass Ihr so tun könnt,
als wäret Ihr an einem anderen Ort. So könnt Ihr
z.B. auf Websites und Internetdienste zugreifen,
die in dem Land, in dem Ihr gerade seid, nicht
verfügbar wären - ob daheim oder im Urlaub!
Damit schlagt ihr Zensur und Geoblocking ein
Schnippchen! Netflix und andere Streaming-Dienste,
die ihre Inhalte nur in den
USA anbieten, von Europa aus
nutzen? Oder deutsches Internet-Fernsehen im
Auslang gucken? Mit Sufshark kein Problem.
Aber das ist noch lange nicht alles! Denn mit
nur einem Surfshark-Konto könnt Ihr wirklich
all Eure Endgeräte im VPN registrieren:
Handies, Notebooks oder sogar Euren SmartTV.
So, und wenn Ihr den Rabattcode "POLITIKDE"
angebt, bekommt Ihr von Surfshark auch noch
einen Rabatt von 83% und obendrein
die ersten 3 Monate gratis dazu. Den
Link zu diesem Angebot findet Ihr in
der Beschreibung unter diesem Video.
Also nichts wie los: besorgt Euch Surfshark und
greift damit gleichzeitig auch
uns finanziell unter die Arme!
Das könnt Ihr übrigens auch direkt – mit
Hilfe des PayPal-Spenden-Links, den ich
Euch ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt habe.
Wir sind Euch für jede Unterstützung dankbar,
denn mit damit helft Ihr uns, Euch in Zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere Videos zu liefern.
So, und nun zurück nach Weißrussland und
unserer spannenden Frage: Wäre es wirklich
möglich, dass Weißrussland Putin aus den
Händen fällt... genau zu dem Zeitpunkt,
an dem es eine Region Russlands werden soll?
Und wie so oft, werfen wir uns zu ihrer
Beantwortung erstmal einen kurzen Blick
in die Geschichte. Auf geht's!
(DAS SOWJET-SILICON-VALLEY)
Kennt Ihr das Videospiel "World of Tanks"? Keine
Angst, jetzt kommt kein zweiter Werbeblock,
auch wenn man ihn perfekt in den
Kontext dieses Videos einbetten könnte.
Gut, sicherlich haben es viele von euch
schon mal gespielt oder davon auf einem
YouTube-Kanal gehört. Es handelt sich
schließlich um eines der beliebtesten
Videospiele der letzten Jahre. Was viele
jedoch gar nicht ahnen: dieses Spiel wurde
in Weißrussland entwickelt! In Weißrussland,
ohne Scheiß! Und nein, es wird nicht von einem
US-Unternehmen mit Büros in Minsk herausgegeben.
Das Unternehmen, das World of Tanks entwickelt,
wurde mit weißrussischem Kapital gegründet und
hat seinen Hauptsitz in der Hauptstadt des Landes.
All das ist überraschend, wenn man bedenkt, dass
Weißrussland eine Diktatur mit etwas mehr als 9
Millionen Einwohnern ist. Aber wir reden hier über
ein Land, das reicher ist, als es scheint. Um es
klar zu sagen: Lukaschenka mag ein abscheulicher
Diktator sein, aber.... er ist kein Dummkopf!
Seit er 1994 an die Macht kam, hat er sich
drei Ziele gesetzt: wirtschaftliche Stabilität,
Frieden und Souveränität. Und das ist
ihm in gewisser Weise auch gelungen.
Dabei gehört Weißrussland zu jenen
ehemaligen Sowjetrepubliken, die den
Übergang zum Kapitalismus nicht
einmal einigermaßen versucht haben,
was sich sogar überdeutlich in
seinen nationalen Symbolen ausdrückt,
welche die sowjetische Ästhetik - wie in
einer Zeitkapsel - beibehalten haben.
Tatsächlich ist die Kommunistische Partei
immer noch Teil der Regierung. Anders als
Russland oder die Ukraine hat Weißrussland
nicht einmal einen Privatisierungsprozess in
Betracht gezogen. Heute befinden sich mehr als 50
% des BIP in den Händen staatlicher Unternehmen.
Der Staat kontrolliert die wichtigsten Sektoren,
vom Gas, das aus Russland kommt, bis zum
wichtigsten Exportgut des Landes: Kalium,
das zur Herstellung von Düngemitteln verwendet
wird! In vielerlei Hinsicht ist Weißrussland
immer noch fest in der Sowjetära verankert.
Wie du dir vorstellen kannst, ist Russland der
wichtigste Handelspartner des Landes. Angesichts
dieses Szenarios könnten viele von euch denken,
dass dieses Land schon immer eine Marionette
des Kremls war, oder? Doch nichts könnte
weiter von der Wahrheit entfernt sein!
(Egal, wer auf weißrussisches Land kommt,
ich werde kämpfen. Auch wenn es
Putin ist. - Alexander Lukaschenka)
Ja, Ihr habt Euch nicht verhört!
Lukaschenka mag ein Verbündeter
Putins sein ... aber er eine reine
Marionette des Kremls will er auf
gar keinen Fall sein. Vielmehr ist seine
Politik sehr pragmatisch. Ja, es stimmt,
die Wirtschaft unterhält ein halbkommunistisches
System und ist eng mit Russland verbunden.
Aber sie haben auch jede Menge Finanzhilfe von der
Europäischen Union erhalten und das ist
noch nicht alles! Im reinsten Stil des
chinesischen Kommunismus hat Lukaschenka
auch Sonderwirtschaftszonen geschaffen.
Hier kommt der berühmte "High Tech Industrial
Park" ins Spiel, der 2005 gegründet wurde.
Es handelt sich um einen Versuch, eine
kleine sowjetische Version des Silicon
Valley zu schaffen. Die Unternehmen in diesem
Industriepark sind von der Zahlung von einer
ganzen Reihe von Steuern und Abgaben befreit.
Sie zahlen z.B. keine Unternehmenssteuern und
auch keine Grundsteuern. Und die Arbeitnehmer
haben einen pauschalen Einkommenssteuersatz von
9 %. Klingt doch nicht schlecht, nicht wahr?
Aber Ihr fragt Euch wahrscheinlich: Hat dieses
sowjetische Silicon Valley wirklich funktioniert?
Nun, ja, das hat es. Um Euch einen Eindruck
zu verschaffen: Im Jahr 2018 gab es im High Tech
Industrial Park bereits 388 Technologieunternehmen
mit 30.000 Beschäftigten. Hier wurde World of
Tanks geboren, neben vielen anderen Spielen.
Das ganze mag jetzt nicht besonders
bedeutend erscheinen, aber bedenkt bitte,
dass wir über ein Land sprechen, dessen
9 Millionen Einwohnern über ein sehr
geringer Einkommen verfügen. Allein dieser
Industriepark macht also mehr als 1,5 % des
gesamten BIP des Landes aus. Mit anderen Worten:
Wir können uns über Lukaschenka lustig machen,
so viel wir wollen. Aber er hat etwas
erreicht, wozu nicht einmal Putin in der
Lage war: eine international wettbewerbsfähige
Technologieindustrie aus dem Boden zu stampfen.
Und auch ein anderes Nachbarland hat
der selbsternannte letzte Diktator
Europas wirtschaftlich ausgestrochen. Ihr
fragt Euch, welches? Haltet Euch fest!
Wie Ihr in dieser Grafik sehen könnte ist Belarus
mittlerweile fast doppelt so reich ist wie die
Ukraine - wohlgemerkt: vor der russischen
Invasion. Und dieser Vergleich ist besonders
schmerzhaft. Die Ukraine ist ein korruptes
Land, ja, aber sie hat wenigstens versucht,
eine Demokratie zu entwickeln. Mit all ihren
Unzulänglichkeiten konnten die Ukrainer ein
gewisses Maß an Freiheit genießen - vor allem
im Vergleich mit ihren weißrussischen Nachbarn.
Das Regime in Minsk hat nicht einmal den Versuch
unternommen, irgendwie demokratisch zu wirken.
Es ist eine Diktatur und steht dazu. Punkt,
aus Ende der Diskussion. Friss oder stirb!
Dafür, dass es zu Fressen gab, wurde
gesorgt. Im wirtschaftlichen Bereich
scheint das belarussische Modell aus irgendeinem
Grund besser zu funktionieren - wohl auch,
weil das "nette Brudervolk" im Osten nicht
immer wieder dazwischenfunkt wie in der Ukraine.
Schließlich wurde die Ukraine eben immer wieder
durch Putins Claquere erfolgreich destabilisiert.
Wer will schon in einem Land unternehmerisch
investieren, wenn dauern ein großer Krieg droht?
Lukaschenka als "braver" Vassall hingegen
konnte unter der schützen Hand Moskaus sein
Versprechen erfüllen: wirtschaftliche Stabilität.
Die Frage ist nur: Wie lange wird diese noch
halten? Welche Konsequenzen hat die Verstrickung
Weißrusslands in den Angriffskrieg und der
zunehmende Vereinigungsdruck aus Moskau?
All das werden wir nun genau
uner die Lupe nehmen.
(DUELL DER ALPHAMÄNNCHEN)
Im Jahr 1990 wurde Weißrussland
von der Sowjetunion unabhängig.
Bis 1994 wurde die Verfassung ausgearbeitet und
Lukaschenka stieg zum Diktator des Landes auf.
Doch 1997 unterzeichnete der damalige
russische Präsident Boris Jelzin mit
Alexander Lukaschenka den "Vertrag über die
Union Belarus und Russland". Dieser Vertrag
stellte den Versuch dar, Russland und Weißrussland
zu einem supranationalen Gebilde zu vereinen.
Und wie Ihr Euch vorstellen könnt, ist eine solche
Sache nicht gerade der feuchte Traum eines jeden
Diktators. Schließlich will ein selbstsüchtiger
Despot sein Land ohne Einschränkungen regieren
können - weder von innen noch von außen.
Und in dem Moment, in dem du eine
Vereinbarung mit jemandem unterschreibst,
der viel größer ist, könntest du die Macht
verlieren, zu tun, was du willst.
Fazit? Lukaschenka sagte zu Jelzin:
Hör zu, Boris, ich werde alles unterschreiben,
was du willst. Wir Russen und Weißrussen sind
Cousins ersten Grades... wir marschieren Hand
in Hand ... und die Sache mit dem gemeinsamen
Staat ist eine dufte Idee mit gaaanz viel
Potential... aber weißt Du... irgendwie
ist das jetzt gerade kein guter Zeitpunkt für
mich... Ich habe zurzeit eine Menge Probleme.
Weißt Du was? Lass uns in ein paar Jahren noch
einmal darüber nachdenken, Kumpel! Na zdrovje!
Tja, und genau dies blieb für Jahrzehnte die
Position von Belarus.... irgendwie war nie die
richtige Zeit, um Ernst zu machen!
Bis, ja, bis dieser feine Herr mit
seiner ehrenwehrten Entourage auftauchte!
Ganz genau! Wladimir Putin. Und wie du weißt, wenn
Putin sich etwas in den Kopf gesetzt hat, kann
er nicht mehr vom Gegenteil überzeugt werden. Im
Jahr 2019 kam Putin zu Lukaschenka und sagte:
- Hey, Alexander, mein Junge... Ich hab neulich
in ein paar alte Akten herumgestöbert
und dabei was Interessantes gefunden:
es scheint, als hättest Du mal eine
Vereinbarung mit uns unterschrieben.
– Ähm, wie? Ich kann mich nicht
erinnern. Ach so! Diese kleine
Partnerschaftsvereinbarung... die hatte ich
schon ganz vergessen! Die habe ich mit Jelzin
unterzeichnet, Du weißt schon... Jelzin...
(GESTE DES TRINKENS)… das war wohl auf ner
Party wo keiner mehr richtig wusste, was er
tut. Hat echt nichts zu bedeuten, der Wisch!
- Alexander Lukaschenka! Oder Lukaschenko!
Oder wie auch immer du deinen Nachnamen
ausgesprochen haben willst. Wir haben hier einen
unterschriebenen Vertrag! Dein Autogramm steht da
drunter! Und du bist sowieso schon total im Verzug
damit, Dich Mütterchen Russland anzuschließen! Ich
denke, ich rufe jetzt den Gerichtsvollzieher
an! Ach ja, das bin ja ich selbst!
Ganz schön praktisch: Kläger, Richter
und Vollstrecker in einer Person. Aber
Du kennst da ja – wenn auch nicht von der
anderen Seite aus, auf der Du jetzt sitzt!
Und so begannen die Beziehungen zwischen Belarus
und Russland zu kippen. Putin und Lukaschenka
lieferten sich ein "Alphamännchen"-Duell.
Vordergründig ging es um Preise für die
Lieferung und den Transit von Öl und Gas.
Wir kennen diese Geschichten. Putin drohte
gar damit, die Öl- und Gaslieferungen zu
unterbrechen und Lukaschenka drohte damit,
Gas aus Russland zu stehlen. Beim Erdöl tat er
das sogar, gab’s dann später aber wieder zurück.
Naja, zwei Streithähne eben, die darum wetteifern,
wer den längeren… Kamm hat. Die zwei zofften
sich bis 2007 und Luki-Boy ging sogar so weit,
den USA schöne Augen zu machen, nur um Putin
in Rage zu bringen. Es sah ganz so aus,
als würden diese beiden Länder zu Feinden
werden – ähnlich wie Russland und die Ukraine.
Doch dann… zeigte sich doch, wer am längeren Hebel
sitzt… Denn Putin verlangte, wenn die Braut nicht
nach seiner Pfeiffe tanzt, die vollständige
Trennung. Und dies hätte jedoch bedeutet,
die bereits bestehende Zollunion zwischen beiden
Ländern komplett aufzuheben und die bisherige
Zollfreiheit für zahlreiche belarussische Waren,
die nach Russland exportiert werden, zu beenden.
Da diese jedoch ca. 50 % des gesamten
belarussischen Exportumfangs ausmachen,
lenkte der Prakmatiker Lukaschenka
doch lieber ein. Friss oder stirb eben.
Damit war die Hackordnung vorerst klargestellt,
der Hausfrieden gerettet. Bis… tja,
bis dem Volk der Fraß des Diktators
immer weniger zu schmecken begann...
(WIR SIND DAS VOLK... WURDE NIEDERGESCHLAGEN)
Im Jahr 2020 wurden in Belarus Wahlen
ausgerufen. Dies bedeutete nicht, dass
das Land plötzlich eine Demokratie geworden wäre.
Die Wahlen in Weißrussland sind dermaßen gezinkt,
dass sich auch hierbei das Regime nicht einmal
die Mühe macht, zu verbergen, dass es menipuliert
und betrügt, bis sich die Balkendiagramme
biegen und die Kuchendiagramme zerkrümeln.
Dabei war Lukaschenka geradezu
gnädig gestimmt. Er war bereit,
die sogenannte "Wahl" mit gerade mal etwas
mehr als 80 % der Stimmen zu gewinnen. Man
kann dem Mann also vieles nachsagen,
aber ein 99%-Narziss ist er nicht!
Allerdings war die Opposition diesmal auch
wirklich gut organisiert. Die Straßen von
Minsk waren voller Demonstranten. Damit Ihr eine
Vorstellung vom Ausmaß der Proteste bekommt:
Lukaschenkas Polizei hat mehr als 6.000
Demonstranten ins Gefängnis gesteckt
und die Anführerin der Opposition,
Sviatlana Tsikhanouskaya, ging ins
Exil nach Litauen. Von dort aus ist sie
zu einem internationalen Symbol geworden.
Und ich weiß, was viele von euch denken - das
belarussische Volk hat sich zusammengeschlossen!
Die Tage des Diktators sind gezählt!
Nun, leider nicht! Es tut mir leid,
Euch enttäuschen zu müssen, aber Lukaschenka
ist immer noch an der Macht. Warum? Erstens,
weil er die Kontrolle über die Armee und die
Polizei hat, zweitens, weil es der Wirtschaft
einigermaßen gut geht und drittens, weil ihm im
letzten Moment sein großer Bruder zur Hilfe kam.
(Proteste in Weißrussland: Putin
ist bereit, Lukaschenko militärische
Unterstützung zu schicken - The Guardian)
Das Ergebnis? Business as usual in Weißrussland.
Die Europäische Union erklärte, sie sei
"zutiefst besorgt" über die Geschehnisse
Belarus. Währenddessen wurde World of Tanks zu
einem der beliebtesten Videospiele in Russland.
Aber... Das Jahr 2022 hat alles verändert und
Ihr könnt Euch sicher schon denken, wieso.
Aber: da ist noch mehr, als die meisten wissen
und was genau werden wir gleich herausfinden.
(KÖNNTE LUKASCHENKA FALLEN?)
Die große Preisfrage lautet nun:
Befinden sichbelarussische Truppen
in der Ukraine? Die Ukraine sagt ja,
aber Weißrussland dementiert ohne Wenn und Aber.
Auf gar keinen Fall. Das Land würde unter keinen
Umständen Soldaten in die Ukraine schicken. Und
Ihr fragt Euch vielleicht, warum? Ich meine,
Lukaschenka ist ja nicht gerade der ängstilche
Typ, wenn es darum geht, seine Meinung zu sagen.
Putin hatte ihn um Hilfe gebeten
und russische Truppen sind seit
mehr als einem Jahr auf weißrussischem
Gebiet stationiert. Darüber hinaus hat
Lukaschenka gerade eine Verfassung verabschiedet,
welche die militärische Souverenität seinen Landes
quasi auf dem Silbertablett an Russland übergibt.
Wieso schickt er dann nicht auch seine
Armee, um Putins Mord- und Raubbanden
direkt unter die Arme zu greifen? Oder,
zumindest... Warum traut er sich nicht,
offen zu sagen, dass er dies vor hat? Hört zu!
('Überläufer und Rücktritte im belarussischen
Militär verhinderten die Beteiligung des Landes
an der Invasion in der Ukraine' - Israel Hayom)
Diese Nachricht ist möglicherweise nicht
wahr. Es handelt sich um Informationen,
die von der belarussischen Opposition stammen.
Aber vieles deutet alles darauf hin, dass sie
wahr ist. Mehreren Quellen zufolge ist sogar der
weißrussische Generalstabschef zurückgetreten.
Es ist nun mal die eine Sache, in Friedenszeiten
einen Diktator zu unterstützen und Dissidenten
zu verprügeln. Skrupel ist da also nicht das
Problem. Es ist jedoch etwas ganz anderes,
sich an einem selbstmörderischen Krieg zu
beteiligen. Die weißrussischen Generäle mögen
böse zu sein, aber sie wollen keine Narren sein.
Tja, und dann kam noch eine große Überraschung.
Denn es stand nach wie vor die Frage
im Raum: Haben weißrussische Truppen
ukrainisches Territorium betreten oder nicht?
Klar ist, dass Weißrussland Spezialkommandos,
Artillerie und Luftverteidigungseinheiten
an seiner Südgrenze zusammenzieht, damit die
Ukraine dort Truppen in Bereitschaft halten muss
und diese dann an anderen Frontabschnitten fehlen.
Aber wie sieht es auf der andere Seite der
Grenze aus? Kämpfen weißrussische Soldaten
auf ukrainischem Boden? Und die Antwort
ist: Ja, das wurde sogar höchst offiziell
bestätigt. Allerdings handelt es sich nicht jene
weißrussichen Soldaten, die man erwarten würde.
(Hunderte von Weißrussen schließen
sich dem Kampf der Ukraine gegen den
russischen Imperialismus an - Atlantic Council)
Ganz genau! Die weißrussische Opposition ist viel
motivierter als die Armee des Regimes.
Einige sind in die Ukraine gegangen,
um dort gegen die Russen zu kämpfen. Andere sind
im Land geblieben und machen Dinge wie diese.
(Weißrussland verhaftet vier Personen, die
versucht haben, die Eisenbahnverbindungen
zur Ukraine zu sabotieren - Euronews)
Wohlgemerkt: dies geht weit über jene
Proteste hinaus, die wir vor zwei Jahren
gesehen haben. Wir sprechen hier von einer
hoch motivierten und gut organisierten
Widerstandsbewegung. Sie ist gewillt,
Lukaschenka die Stirn zu bieten und dieser
will nun sogar wieder die Todesstrafe
auf derartige Sabotageakte einführen. Die
Nervosität im Regime steigt also merklich.
Aber das ist noch nicht alles! Ob mit oder ohne
Truppen in der Ukraine, Weißrussland leidet
unter fast den gleichen Wirtschaftssanktionen wie
Russland. Und das erklärt Nachrichten wie diese.
(Weißrusslands größter Spielehersteller verlässt
das Land - sowie auch Russland - Steamgameguides)
Und sie sind nicht die Einzigen! Praktisch das
gesamte Belarussische Silicon Valley,
über das wir vorhin gesprochen haben,
befindet sich auf der Flucht und mit ihm alle
hochqualifizierten Arbeitskräfte und Unternehmer.
Wir sprechen hier von Unternehmen, die ihre
gesamte Belegschaft in andere Länder verlegen.
Klar, in Russland passiert ähnliches, aber
für Belarus ist das allesweitaus schwerer zu
verdauen als für Putins Riesenreich. Warum?
Nun, vergesst nicht, dass Weißrussland kein
Erdgas und kein Öl hat. Alexander Lukaschenka
ist in einer viel schlechteren Lage als sogar
Wladimir Putin. Ihr wollt Zahlen sehen? Dann
werft einfach einen Blick auf diese Grafik.
Anders als der russische Rubel hat
sich der belarussische Rubel nicht
von der straken Abwertung erholt. Mit
anderen Worten: Das Land hat unter den
Sanktionen gelitten, war aber nicht
in der Lage, die jene Währungsmanöver
und Kurskosmetik durchzuführen, von der
wir Euch im letzten Video erzählt haben.
Aber nicht nur das! Im Gegensatz zu Putin
hat es Lukaschenka mit einer um Welten
besser organisierten Opposition zu tun.
Ich meine: Wer wäre Putins größter Gegner?
Wahrscheinlich Alexej Nawalny, der trotz seiner
vielen Unterstützer im Internet... im Gefängnis
sitzt! In Weißrussland ist Lukaschenkas
Hauptgegnerin Swiatlana Tsikhanouskaya,
die sich gerade mit allen möglichen Staats-
und Regierungschefs der Welt trifft.
Aber das ist noch nicht alles! Anders als Putin
hat Lukaschenka nicht die uneingeschränkte
Unterstützung der Armee. Es ist schwer zu sagen,
wie viele Menschen ihn unterstützen und wie viele
bereit wären, sich gegen ihn zu erheben. Aber
es ist klar, dass er es sich nicht leisten kann,
mit dem Feuer zu spielen. Denn so wie es
aussieht, scheint er sich auf sein eigenes
Militär im Falle eines Aufstandes weniger
verlassen zu können als auf das Putins.
So ist er dem Kremlherrscher nun auf Gedeih
und Verderb ausgeliefert und befindet sich
damit in einer doppelten Zwickmühle.
Denn um ihm seine Loyalität zu beweisen,
müsste er ihm mit seiner Armee
in der Ukraine zu Hilfe eilen.
Seine stehenden Streitkräfte sind jedoch
nicht groß, gerade mal 46.000 Soldaten.
Diese könnten nach den Erfahrungen, welche
die Russen mit den Ukrainern gemacht hatte,
schnell erschöpft sein. Dann müsste er
zumindest einen Teil der rund 340.000
Reservisten mobilisieren. Doch diesen
traut der Diktator noch weniger über
den Weg. Er müsste sie für einen Einsatz in
der Ukraine mit Sturmgewehren bewaffnen und
diese könnten sie dann sehr schnell gegen
ihn selbst widmen. Er würde damit also nur
seinen eigenen Gegnern im Land Waffen
in die Hand geben. Ein Teufelskreis.
Eine Revolution in Belarus würde natürlich
auch für Putin gerade zur Unzeit kommen,
seine Armee ist in immer höherem Maße in der
Ukraine gebunden und die Zeit spielt gegen ihn.
Der Pragmatiker Lukaschenka lobte nun
schon vorsorglich sogar die Taktik
der ukrainischen Armee und maßregelte
seine Generäle wie kleine Schuljungen,
dass die belarussischen Streitkräfte
von ihr lernen sollten. Er weiß,
dass ein komplettes Bataillon aus Weißrussen
bereits auf ukrainischer Seite kämpft und
diese - wenn sie nach dem Krieg heim kommen
– vom Volk wie Helden gefeiert werden. Und
als Hoffnungsträger für die Befreiung des eigenen
Landes von der Diktatur und dem russischen Joch.
Das ganze ist ein großes Dominospiel und die
Steine scheinen schon ziemlich stark zu kippen.
Wir werden die Entwicklungen in den Nachbarstaaten
Russlands daher im Auge behalten und uns im
nächsten Video einen weiteren Brandherd für
Russland ansehen: Moldowa und Transnistrien.
Und bis dahin ist die Frage an Euch gerichtet:
Könnte Alexander Lukaschenka stürzen? Glaubt
Ihr wirklich, dass Putin genügend Truppen
schicken könnte, um ihn zu schützen, jetzt,
wo fast seine gesamte Armee in der
Ukraine gebunden ist? Ist es möglich,
dass die USA oder Europa etwas unternehmen,
um Lukaschenkas Abgang zu beschleunigen?
Wie immer sind wir schon auf Eure
Beiträge im Kommentarbereich gespannt!
Ich hoffe, dass Euch dieses Video gefallen hat
und Ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
habt. Falls ja, gebt uns bitte ein Like, teilt es
mit Euren Freunden und vergesst nicht das Abo mit
Glöckchen, um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen. Natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von Euch, mit der Ihr uns helft,
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen. Den
PayPal-Link dazu findet Ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video.
Macht’s gut und bis bald!